so the first thing i wanted to ask was
what it was like working with john as a
director
it was wonderful i mean the there's just
sort of superlatives to say about john
unfortunately no sort of damning
criticisms he's
really better than you think he could be
and you already expected him to be so
wonderful
so um yeah i i was
the reason i did the movie was as soon
as i heard he was making movie i wanted
to be a part of it in any capacity
and and then the experience was better
than i could have
imagined john's very you know very very
capable
as a um director and writer as
as we're see as we see in this script
um i also i want to throw in a
big um shout out to bobby bukowski who
worked behind the camera
and um i saw i think
john and he had a really good
relationship bobby
explained beyond
uh maybe an extra shot here to cover
cover this scene i think um jon stewart
was in
in good hands and and a good partnership
with bukowski
made a difference when you were
preparing for this film did john
want you to watch anything specific like
mr deeds goes to town or mr smith goes
to washington
or any sort of films to kind of give you
an idea of what he was going for
did he for you mckenzie he didn't for me
the only
sort of stuff he gave me or recommended
this book on wisconsin local politics
that i read
um i forget the name of it now but uh it
was it was sort of about what happened
but the changing political ties in
wisconsin that was interesting and
um and that is it
when you're playing these sort of small
town characters how do you make sure
that they feel
real and lived in as opposed to the kind
of the caricature
that like a character like gary has in
his mind of who these people
are i think just being a real person and
not assuming that if you live in a small
town you have any sort of
essential character difference to
somebody who lives in a city obviously
like your environment shapes you but
um uh yeah i think maybe not approaching
it as though
there needs to be an extra layer of
character because they grew up in this
small
town and i was also kind of curious
um you know your characters i don't want
to give anything away but
there are certain motivations that you
have to keep hit in
and i was curious how do you sort of
keep that in the back of your mind when
you're playing a scene so that
the film then works again on a repeat
viewing
i think that's the point of that is to
not give not give it away to the
audience
um there's a big reveal uh
for this film several maybe several
reveals
and and um
yeah my relationship with uh
the father-daughter relationship there's
a subtext going on
that that the audience
cannot know about you know but um so
yeah you
you keep it in mind sure chris
we also we have a lot of muppet fans on
our staff and
um some were kind of curious with you
know your your character playing the
villain in that in the muppets
um how much that changed from the final
cut of the film
oh gosh you know i mean i i was
thrilled to be a part of that i i i
completely missed
the muppets uh era you know and had no
idea
how how strongly people
adore the muppets and when we shot it in
los angeles
knowing that all these actors that live
around
los angeles were daily
daily approaching the director the
producer saying
can i do anything any kind of cameo to
just be a part of this so
i was totally ignorant of uh how
how popular this uh the muppets were
mckenzie i wanted to ask you what was it
like working with
hiro mirai on station eleven and how far
did you guys get into
production before you had to shut down
well a stationary was always shooting in
two parts part in the winter
and part in the summer so my partner
hadn't begun shooting yet
hiro and patrick and uh they were
shooting sort of a different
era of the show that took place in
chicago in the winter so they only got a
couple episodes in and then we were
supposed to start shooting again
the the portion that i was in in june
and
of course that hasn't happened so i'm on
pins and needles
to find out what it's like is it kind of
weird going in given the subject matter
of station 11 and what we're going
through right now
i mean the irony would be impossible to
miss
that our pandemic show got canceled by a
pandemic but i think it's giving us a
lot of lived experience to draw from
wow thank you guys so much for your time
and i hope you all have a great day
thank you thank you